[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this is our Bible question and answer
program one of our favorite programs
here at Secrets unsealed and some TV and
we say that a lot because it's true uh
for a number of reasons one it gives us
an opportunity to study the word of God
it gives us also an opportunity to find
out what's on your mind and your heart
uh gives us a chance to sort of dialogue
with you over the Airways to um instruct
and also to teach ourselves as as we're
teaching because we like to study we
like to learn we like to know uh also so
this is a favorite program my name is CA
Murray and I'm in the company of Pastor
David Salazar one of our newest
additions uh to the ministry somebody
that we have come to learn and love and
like right away is a good guy good
student of the word and a good addition
to the ministry everybody here just
about is bilingual except me David speak
Spanish and English beautifully and is a
student of the word so we he's the the
the third part of the Triumph very long
with myself and Pastor Bohr and uh we
really enjoy him he is happy now smiling
because his wife is here and his
daughters amen he was here alone a
couple uh weeks ago and now he's gone
and got his family so now that grin on
his face is occasioned by his wife and
two beautiful daughters and I know he's
happy about that indeed I am very happy
to be here with the family as well so
thank you pastors we make you this
pledge each time we uh begin this
program
we will answer your questions from the
word of God and that's very very
important to us because we are rather
late in this Earth's history too late to
Banter about
the will of man or the mind of man or
the words of man we want the word of the
Lord From The Lord so when you send in
your questions we guarantee that if an
answer can be found in the word of God
we will find that answer and give it to
you from the word of God because you
need to hear the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth and you need
to hear it from the word of the Lord
amen so we make it that promise that
it's going to come from the Lord back up
with scripture so that you know that
what we say to you is not our opinion
but what has been revealed to us in the
word of God should you like to get in on
the fun Should you want to be a part of
this program we encourage you to do so
by writing to us at TV at some TV that's
TV at s-u-m-tv.org
and we'll get to your questions a lot
the list is rather impressive and
somewhat long in English and in Spanish
and so it's going to take us some time
to get through some of these questions
as you will see today sometimes we have
to take our time with certain questions
others we can pass through quickly but
we don't want to dismiss any question by
running running through it too fast
so we're going to take our time get
through to your question sooner or later
stick with us we will answer your
questions we make you that promise now
uh Pastor if you will pray and then
we'll we'll begin the program perfect
let's pray as we ask and seek the Lord
for guidance
Heavenly Father Lord as we come to you
this moment of study we pray that you
will lead us into all truth please
provide us the holy spirit that we may
be led and also be able to share from
your word from your inspiration the
answers that our friends who are
watching are seeking I pray they will
bless us and place perjured lips from
our Lord or self-talk and may you only
provide us the truth we pray this in
Jesus name amen amen amen
all right Pastor CA we have these uh
very uh interesting question I would
like to ask or actually share with you
and since you are a source of a lot of
understanding on wisdom I'll ask this
question and you help me answer this
comes from Linda from the Caribbean from
Trinidad actually and she asked the
following question says good evening
panel my question is is there any
biblical fact on the slavery issue of
the black race
the Hebrews were enslaved 400 years and
according to history this is the 400
plus year as we know the blacks from all
over the world suffers Prejudice and
Justice more than any race Under the Sun
is there anything thanks for thanks
God's richest blessings from Trinidad
the Caribbean that's what Linda asks and
I believe the question is basically in
regards to you know she comparing the
Hebrew people enslaved in Egypt for 400
years and is there any there any I guess
linked to the black race being a slave
for 400 years or more than that
um let me take just a minute to go
through a number of things as I look
look at this question because it does
come up from time to time
um
there's so much to say I don't know
quite where to start but I I will start
by saying this
you will not find any exposition of the
black experience in America or in the
world in the Bible per se you can find
parallels as to what to do when you are
persecuted you can find information on
how to respond to those who slap your
one cheek and what you should do with
the other you you you could uh find
information on how to behave when
someone does something evil or vengeful
against you but as pertains to the black
slavery experience per se the answer uh
Linda is is no
um a couple of things come to mind
there is a a history in in this world
that whenever you have
people of lighter skin and people of
Darker skin and this is throughout the
planet I mean not only in the United
States and uh but there tends to be this
differentiation
uh uh and and racism
Ellen White lets us know or encourages
us or informs us that we will have
racism in one form or another
up until the second coming of the Lord
and that is because of the the evil
heart of of men so racism is just one
expression of any number of expressions
of the of the the evil that's in man's
heart we tend to reject people who look
differently than us who talk differently
than us uh I'm a black person you are a
brown person some of our experiences
overlap you know right um I've I've had
a cross burned on my lawn you know I
know what that's all about wow um my my
best friend in the ministry Pastor
Bailey uh had a cross burned in his
house when he grew up in Mississippi wow
so this experience is is is
ground into did I say uh The History of
the United States now having said that
slavery in the United States was a
peculiar institution it was unlike any
other form of slavery now it has been
well said that there were African tribes
who conquered other African tribes and
and made them slaves well that that goes
that's as old as is history right but
when you conquer a person and they
become your slave there's no history of
the dehumanization that took place in
American slavery in African slavery or
even other kinds of slavery
um I'm looking at the book of Philemon
just one chapter and I would take a lot
of time it could take a lot of time to
read but I won't
but
um onesimus is there and Paul is is he's
a runaway slave right Paul is sending
him back to his master but slavery in
Bible times does not like American
slavery there were rules on how you
treat your slave you know you didn't
slap him you didn't abuse him you didn't
beat him uh which was so common in
American slavery so he's he's telling
the the slave owner receive him like a
brother he's not only your slave he will
serve you but realize he's your brother
in Christ now you are brothers more than
Master owner and slave right so there's
a there's a different flavor to this
kind of slavery than than the American
institution of of slavery truth be known
every Protestant denomination has had to
deal with slavery all of them I'm
thinking about the Methodist Church in
particular the Methodist Church divided
United Methodist Church divided over the
right that some Methodist Bishops were
assuming to own slaves and uh there were
other Methodist Bishops who said this is
wrong
so the Methodist Church splintered
and many of the African groups that came
out of it you had the African Methodist
Episcopal Church the AME Church in in
and around New York City you have the
AME Zion Church African Methodist
Episcopal Zion Church these were black
offshoots of the United Methodist Church
because the Methodist Church had to
wrestle with slavery well so did the
Adventist Church to this day and and to
be frank we've got
black original conferences and white or
state conferences now with things being
what they are none of these are as pure
as they once were you know people are
going to church where they want to go to
church doing what they want to do but
you still got the structure right and
what maintains the structure now I think
more than racial uh separation is
financial separation we're making money
over here and you're making money over
there you're not going to give us your
money we're not going to give you ours
you know so so what holds that structure
is really more financial than racial but
um
uh she's talking about the 400th year
well most historians Peg
the the first slaves coming to the
United States in 1619. you've heard of
the 1619 project which sort of dates The
History of the United States back to
1619. so it's 400 plus years Israel was
in Egypt not 400 years to the day what
400 years generally you know right so
generally she's correct but there's I
don't think there's any Biblical
significance at least I don't see any
between the 400 years of Egyptian Bond
or the Hebrew bondage and the 400 years
of slavery here in the United States
it's kind of just coincidental that we
we've come to a 400 years no it makes
sense absolutely yeah yeah and Pastor
CIA you know obviously what you
mentioned the abuse or the type of
slavery that happened in America it's uh
and has happened probably in the most
modern history in in the world it's it's
really a terrible expression of immense
cruelty you know of the abuse of power
of those who had the power I guess but
to say that you know that a particular
uh you know situation is necessarily
biblically connected it's probably you
know hard to unless there's prophecy in
it there's really nothing there to
connect it to the Bible however you know
we have seen that throughout history
there's been different races that have
been persecuted have been abused have
been put into you know and one of them
is the Jewish you know race I mean after
they rejected the Lord you know they
asked and they said you know his blood
you know children so our children it is
the most cursed if you will race in a
sense biblically speaking is the Jewish
raising in that sense that they rejected
Christ the Redeemer and they accepted
the penalty of that and and we have seen
unfortunately through the history as
well that they have been you know
there's a lot of anticism you know and
people still have a lot of hate towards
them and so it's it's sad and of course
I I can understand probably uh Linda you
know who might have experienced that or
has experienced some sort of rejection
it's a horrible thing you know and I
wish and I pray that we can make a
difference as Adventists as delivers in
Jesus you know to overcome these
separations that really are man-made and
are from the evil heart yes and come
together in one as Christ wants us to be
amen amen I well said uh David
um let me give you just a couple things
and then we can move on to our next
question
um
when they said his blood be on us and
our children uh they doomed themselves
to
a life that
this went on thousands of years so if
you're talking about punishment and and
rejection they got a thousand year Head
Start you know on on on black Africans
although that is not to minimize the
Middle Passage right the hundreds of
thousands of Africans brought over and
killed right
to show that the Lord is is is watching
out for his people
um
Ellen White saw the Civil War several
years before it took place she predicted
it
she said that the Lord was going to
punish the south for the high crime of
slavery and the north for benefiting
from it
if you read and this is what got me
started I looked at the death tolls of
of people in the Civil War fifty
thousand in a day you know 750 000 just
just numbers how do they get that kind
of death with the kind of they didn't
have big planes and bonds like we have
today so how are so many people being
died being killed
Ellen White lets us know that Satan had
his hand in the Civil War that he was
Behind These large death tolls that that
actually
generals North and South were
communicating with evil spirits who were
leading uh troops into to uh battle and
and Illinois says Satan Delights in war
and he Delights to see men mowed down
like grass and this took place in the
Civil War so there was a demonic aspect
to the Civil War wow what is also
interesting is that
um
J.N Loughborough was in the audience
when the mayor mayor the governor of
Kansas uh was giving a speech he was not
Adventist but he said this
he said after the Emancipation
Proclamation was signed
we had come over to the Lord's Side
we were aware God wanted us to be he
wanted to free the black African in
America
if you look at the history of the Civil
War the north never lost another major
battle
after the Emancipation Proclamation
because God had taught the United States
the lesson that he wanted to teach at
the First Battle of Bull Run so you got
me on my subject you know at the First
Battle of Bull Run the first battle of
Manassas Junction it was called bull run
right The South was winning
and and Ellen White says had the South
one
the war would have been over slavery
would have gone on that the Lord didn't
want that he didn't want this war to end
any sooner than
uh it would have to to end to teach this
country the lessons you got to let black
people free
so she says an angel came down waved his
hand and there was confusion in the
ranks North thought they were winning
they yet they began to retreat the South
pressed the battle and of course it it
there were men and women in carriages
they thought it was going to be a quick
War a couple hours we'll go ahead and
have some sandwiches and some lunch and
we'll we'll go back home uh of course
there was panic but it let the North and
the South know that you're going to be
in for a long long war and Illinois said
it was going to take that kind of
Carnage to wrench the hand of the slave
from the hand of of his master
Jan laferral writes after the uh
passing passage of the Emancipation
Proclamation the north never lost a
battle now he heard this from the lips
of the governor of Kansas who was not a
seven-day Adventist he was just a
historian who looked at what was
happening and could see that we had come
around to God's side that's a quote and
God was ready now to end the war so he
did
here's all we know God had looked out
for for black people
everybody knows or certainly the most
historians of black people know the name
Rosa Parks right she sat uh on the bus
up front would not sit in the back what
they don't know
is that 10 years earlier a Seventh-Day
Adventist Woman by the name of Irene
Morgan kirkaldi she was living in Long
Island New York that's where I met her
went to her house sat and talked with
her prayed with her
in the state of Virginia she did the
exact same thing that Rosa Parks did she
refused
to move to the back of the bus was
arrested sent to court
her lawyer who took her case all the way
to the Supreme Court was Thurgood
Marshall
uh the famous Supreme Court Justice
she was a Seventh-Day Adventist she was
a member of the Ebenezer Seventh-day
Adventist Church in Freeport New York
now the reason we know Rosa Parks and we
don't know Irene Morgan kirkhaldi is one
thing
television
Irene Morgan kirkaldi refused to sit in
the back of the bus in 1945.
Rosa Parks refused to sit in the back of
the bus in 1954.
that 10-year period a new thing happened
television television television
television made the Civil Rights
Movement personal people in the north
would sit home eating their dinner and
watch the Nightly News and see blacks
being beaten dogs set on them all these
kind of things happen so
television made Martin Luther King it
made Rosa Parks all of these these
wonderful men who did such great works
it was known now because of Television
Irene Morgan called pre-television so
her name was not known only a very few
know she in fact Bill Clinton gave her
the medal of freedom I think it was the
medal of freedom which is the highest
civilian version give somebody
but when she stood for that most people
didn't know the name they had never
heard of her but she did the exact same
thing Rosa Parks did she just didn't
have television cameras there to to
record it all but she was a Seventh-Day
Adventist so God was looking out for for
his children now my last little bit that
I'm done
we have in the Adventist Church now
Regional conferences
and state conferences some people call
the regional conferences black
conferences right
um
and there's there's cross breeding a lot
because in in the churches I passed it I
was in northeastern conference for many
many years
um I had whites in my church I had
blacks in my church at Latinos in my
church you know it's it's kind of
homogenized what what's there still is
the structure the superstructure above
the congregational level
um
Regional conferences began for the most
part January 1 1945.
they were a result of a number of things
but the the straw that broke the camels
back was there was a very fair-skinned
black woman about your color you're very
fair thing but she was black
she was she was brought into the
Washington sanitarium now it's
Washington Adventist Hospital
wheeled into the hospital
and when they looked at her chart and
her records They found out that she was
she was black well she was wheeled out
into the Hall
and uh it's supposed to be transferred
to Friedman's Hospital which is just
over the line in Virginia
by the time they got her to Friedman's
hospital she had contracted pneumonia
and died
very very sad history of The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church your church my church
the black leadership said
enough
there was another incident just like it
where a woman was wheeled out into the
Hall
uh didn't die but refused service
and so they said enough we're going to
start our own conferences and the next
year the regional conferences uh were
begun were created so that's the history
of the have they outlived their
usefulness
an argument could be made right you know
um I've preached the whites I preached
the blacks I preacher Latinos you know
uh and accepted by by everybody so I
don't know if we have to there are some
differences in worship service yeah
that's true but we're all Seventh-Day
Adventists we all believe the same thing
uh my wife is is is Spanish she's from
Panama you know and last I look we get
along pretty good you know we don't we
don't have any problems before that and
and we praise the Lord for that uh my
mother's Brothers
uh my mother's from Canada all of her
brothers married Caucasians so all of my
cousins my first cousins are mixed race
so we are very comfortable you know
flowing in about if we if we had a a
a meeting would look like the U.N you
know does all colors shapes sizes and
and shades so we can get along uh and we
have to get along the the the head of
this ministry
is a white German
and I've liked him from the first day I
met him you know I get along with Pastor
Ward very very well you can see beyond
color you know I people say well I when
I see you I don't see color well I don't
necessarily believe that because I'm
black I've was born black and a dye
black so you see the color the thing is
you don't let the color impede on how
you treat a person absolutely you are my
friend absolutely we have not known each
other that long right but I like you you
know I do that's right and I'm very
comfortable around you that's the way it
ought to be you know
um and and that's what I think the Lord
wants from all of us so uh God has
looked out for us
um as people of color God God fights for
the downtrodden he always does and he
always will and somehow we're going to
get by this because we are going to go
into heaven together not through
separate Gates not I live in the just
side of the tracks and you live on the
other side of the tracks I don't think
that's how it's going to be God is going
to help us to overcome this and do his
work for for the Lord amen Pastor I
think that you have given us a history
class and and really uh very uh profound
understanding of really you know what
happened here and in America what
happened in in this country and how
really we are to
um see future you know how we're to
realize that we are not to continue
putting these divisions or allowing
these segregation to come in our hearts
but really in Christ become one you know
we are to have that Unity if we are to
receive the Holy Spirit and to spread
the gospel as one you know group and at
the end of the day the the world is
going to turn towards one group you know
it's not going to be what we're not
necessarily colored or race but that
group that together in unity have the
Testament of Jesus keep his Commandments
have the patience so it is important
that we you know we
I guess have that aim in our hearts and
really ask the Lord to take away those
seeds of segregation separation you know
of seeing you know one another
differently and and really I believe
that we are to prepare for that Unity
that the Lord wants his church to have
you know yes we talk about separation
and and we're sitting in our
air-conditioned houses one day we're
gonna have to share the same cave
together you know running from running
from from the powers that are going to
persecute us if you're going to share
the same cave together then you better
be able to share a little something now
you know that's I think that's the will
of God and you know these Ministries is
mentioned is a Ministry that is really
uh then praise the Lord we're all you
know together is you know well uh let's
continue with the next question because
hopefully we have enough time for for
for to go into that
um and so the question is comes from uh
well I guess from Steve and Steve tells
us the following says I am an Adventist
I have a question about the 6000 years
of sin Ellen I must mean something white
has made comments in various writings
about Satan having 6 000 years to work
his work of deception following
bible-given genealogy and prophecy
concerning end times we know this time
frame is about exhausted
all I am wondering is if anywhere in the
Bible I can do a study on the 6 000
years of sin or is this a spirit
prophecy comment only
so that's a question that Steve does and
I guess he he comes with the I mean
there is actually
several uh quotes once per prophecy and
he's writing that a one who is found in
the saravagis page 413 yes another one
in
the very controversy page 659 that do
mention this concept of six thousands
years for six thousand years the uh you
know the human race has been you know
insane and that kind of thing but we
have to I believe Pastor that you know
we have to uh not use or not use those
six thousand years Concepts to put a
date a mark of end moment I mean the
Lord has that and he's the only one that
knows what that and then there it is but
I think it's a general concept that she
uses and of course we've seen in in in
the Psalms 90 verse 4 and 2nd Peter 3 8
that the Bible speaks of you know for
God one day he's like a thousand years
you know so we see these concepts of
thousands of years and I I suppose that
is a concept that biblically speaking
Steve could use to understand or say you
know there's
sixth hour or a thousand years but uh
Revelation 20 20 verse 22 7 I mean verse
two to seven mentioned the millennial in
heaven so there are concepts of
thousands of years in the Bible but
specifically six thousand years uh only
is is more of a concept that Andrew
White mentions I don't know what your
thoughts are on this I I think you're
very true or very correct the I had the
the the great controversy 659 uh
reference the 6 000 years was not meant
to be something that you could hang a
date on one of the things the Lord does
not want us to do is try to handicap him
uh and try to predict when he's going to
come back we we we know the season we
know the the time but we don't know the
exact date and and he's not trying to
give us clues that we can use to Peg an
exact date he doesn't want us to do that
he wants us to live in a Perpetual state
of Readiness
um we're gonna have to let this one go
because our time is getting away from us
again we wish you both Grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
we'll see you again soon and we'll try
to just wrap up this question in the
next program God bless
[Music]
good
morning
[Music]
foreign